have to talk about how athletes are
ensuring their body parts Lionel Messi
for starters tops the list with a 900
million dollar policy on just his left
foot yes just his left foot Cristiano
Ronaldo opted to have both of his legs
insured for 144 million while David
Beckham opted to not only cover his legs
but his full body for 225 million it's
not just the footballers though F1
driver Fernando Alonso had his thumbs
insured for 13.33 million dollars oh you
thought thumbs were weird try hair
former Steelers DB Troy Polamalu had his
hair insured for one million dollars
hair had been targeted at least once on
the field by opponents so I guess it's
understandable